はい。この前、もう…
可愛い子の人がいるかもしれない。
2年前、アラスカ行った時さ、色々。
アラスカラって言ってた。
昔、メンメン、飛行機ってアラスカ行っても止まってたんでしょ?
うん。
空港だけ?それとも、一泊ぐらい止まってた?
見たことない、アラスカは。
でも、アラスカはちょっと降りたりしてみたけどね。
綺麗だけど、やっぱり一年中いたら楽そうよね。
うん。でも、夏が一番いいらしい。
全然熱くならないから。
ちょっとしらない。
はい。
キャンパーショー。
私は、今度はリクちゃんをメンメンに来ていないから、あの…。
前に来た時は、パパとか一人だったよね。
うん。
だから、誰も来たなんて思ってないけど。
一人でできたら、ちょっと…。
あなたの、彼女のボーイフレンドができたんじゃない?って言われる。
いやいや、何か来たじゃん。一人で。
そうだった気はする。
うん。いや、今回じゃないけど。
だけど、みんなが見てるわ。いわゆるボーイフレンドっていうのは、みんなシンサーだったね。
あ、そっか。
そのシンサー、今、セサスっていうところに映っちゃった中国人のシンサー。
あ、もう。
すごくいい方でね、よく来てたのね。
その頃、運転してたから、帰りを伝えたりして。
へぇ。
えぇ。
え、まだ、まだ帰っちゃったんですか?
うん。
今、もう、ずっと、セサスっていうところにいるの。
あー。
だけど、なんか、そこ行く道は分からなくて、
うん。
だから、あの、一回、うちに来たから、
今日帰り、道を覚えるかもしれない。
「行ってあげる」って言ったんで、
ちょっと、その頃に行ったんで、
で、そしたら、あの、残念ながら、めちゃくちゃ混んじゃった。
あ、あ。
それで、最後になって、ほとんど、こう、動かないくらい混んじゃって、
そしたら、突然ね、ここからもう、歩いた方が早いから、
もう、行くね、バイバイとか、
あ、バイって降りちゃった。
うん。